il est 13 heures ces gestes jeu cela les
répètent depuis ce matin qui ramasse et
une autre avait depuis à 6 heures nous
sommes au carbet l'exploitant agricole
prépare sa deuxième commande de la
journée 500 kilos de giraud - a livré à
fort de france avant 18h 30 ans déjà
qu'il fait ce métier votre courage et
parce qu'on est sous le soleil sous la
pluie faut être patient parce qu'on
plante quelque chose c'est pas tout ça
vous donne de l'argent bon si c'est des
tomates vous dit pas c'est que si ces
trois mois du mois il faut savoir
atteindre les 12 mois les trois mois
pour l'armée quad pour avoir de l'argent
mais les vocations sont de plus en plus
rares son voisin a préféré louer sa
parcelle pour l'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques
autrefois considérée comme le grenier de
la martinique le nord de lille voit
diminuer chaque année son nombre
d'agriculteurs le secteur qui représente
désormais à peine plus de 10% des
emplois un métier difficile contraignant
et pour beaucoup insuffisamment rémunéré
est toujours en tête les ovales mais
c'est si vous vendez à s'évader à ces
services là c'est au calme alors à
propos gourrama sinaly gbe cela pour qui
nos gaulois 5 et aux adultes est pas mal
non plus beaux idéaux ce pépiniériste
vend essentiellement aux agriculteurs en
cinq ans il a vu son chiffre d'affaires
diminuer de 20% l'an dernier il a dû se
séparer d'un salarié sur les trois qui
l'employait c'est par rapport au fond si
bien parce qu'il ya beaucoup de le tiers
disent on plantera kahn quitte à
utiliser par les agriculteurs
donc je pense que c'est principalement
pour ça on ne voit pas de jeunes
agriculteurs donc
on est mené par exclus des jeunes qui
préfèrent se tourner vers d'autres
secteurs comme les services et les
administrations
75 % des actifs du nord de l'île malgré
les apparences
laurine et d'ivan ne font pas exception
lui veut être coiffeur l employé de
bureau
tu te vois travailler dans l'agriculture
pourquoi pas l'agriculture c'est en
conséquence sa pieuse ce soleil tout ça
ne me va pas
heureusement le secteur suscite encore
des vocations inattendue à 64 ans cet
ancien menuisier souhaitent se
reconvertir en exploitant agricole comme
ses parents à l'époque mais il est vrai
qu'on est bien loin ici de la démarche
mercantile
c'est une logique de la vie qu'on sera
en contact avec la nature
parce que je me suis rendue compte
qu'elle est fait pour nous en ce 1 0 ne
peut rien faire et en effet pour elle
aussi elle a besoin de l'entretien et
nous aussi ça nos entretiens à terme jeu
cela envisagent d'embaucher is il aura
certainement du mal à convaincre laurine
et d'ivan sans doute aura-t-il plus de
chance avec l'un des 600 jeunes
martiniquais qui continuent de se former
chaque année aux métiers de
l'agriculture